deux hauts fonctionnaires et sénatoriale
mise à jour avec de l'excellent contenu
ces partis déjà une refonte graphique
aujourd'hui on blague plus on change la
culotte comme à chaque fois la culotte
rose à fleurs elle est magnifique
il est maintenant l'heure d'aller à
l'école et vous allez voir mais il est
vrai que ça change et [ __ ] ça pourquoi
je lance le jeu [ __ ] c'est tellement
beau alors déjà le couloir jusqu'à
l'école est beaucoup moins grand il ya
plus la petite fontaine était derrière
l'école cela est génial cela me plaît
beaucoup
alors comment on court déjà quoi quand
j'ai fait ça j'ai fait un petit tour on
inspecte un petit peu les lions est
d'accord [ __ ] maintenant le terrain et
beaucoup ok y'a une une lors du gymnase
avec eux de quoi faire de l'athlétisme
ayant béret s'élance sur le terrain
walker ridge dans sa culotte donc la
nature on laisse les vestiaires pour se
laver à droite la helaba gaulle je
jugerai un truc en fait pasqua d'avoir
kidnappé quelqu'un est ce que la pièce
pour kidnapper est encore dans le
gymnase à ok y'a pas les pièces encore
voix écoutée on va aller inspecter du
coup la nouvelle école à il paraît
qu'ils agents quatre fois plus de
cheminots pièce va avoir du mal à se
trouver à mais mon gars c'est immense
comment on va faire pour trouver la
pièce faut qu'on trouve la pièce où il
ya la petite caisse je m'embête c'est
que j'ai tout fait une faute en comble
au ces au milieu de l'école la petite
heure la petite fontaine
c'est de toute beauté oh oui déjà ça
c'est bon ça c'est parfait hop hop
ok on a les deux on a les deux on a de
quoi les seizièmes attendons juste
trouver la caisse [ __ ] au occulte club
c'est quoi ce délire à tonga c'est
nouveau ça excellent savez c'est
terrifiant alors là en ont joué au web
c'est vraiment la [ __ ] c'est mon gars
ça se voit trop c'est une petite pièce
nul comme ça à côté d'escalier alors
lier leurs concerts baptisés que
quelqu'un nous suivent six jeux sympas
et [ __ ] olala attend lui c'est
toujours le king a regardé déjà il est
uni qui ce soit sur la fontaine et pas
les autres me donner un style excuse moi
est-ce que sinon au pire si je
l'anesthésiste devant les gens
pourraient l'amener jusqu'à la caisse
faut qu'on essaye boss ok c'est bien
sérieux je l'attends salle
tout le monde m'a vu tous les mecs tu te
rappelles sempai
ok on est bon on a la capacité de
maîtriser la biologie on est un max de
réputation va passer à l'action bien au
plus tard toi viens là vient la viande
vers l'arctique a demandé bien là bien
là vient la jeune blonde avec papa non
ma vie nuls ma vie est tellement pourri
mais qu'est ce que j'ai aujourd'hui
allait du coup faut qu'on aille se
changer au qatar faut jamais toucher
l'ag du sort sur moi en fait de la
pousser le truc mais yann moix le gars
au keops je me lave d'accord j'ai put
enfin c'est chiant du coup maintenant tu
dois te [ __ ] à poil et l'avait
complètement quand tu quelques heures
mais ça ou me suis ramassé mes fringues
pour l'instant mais je sais pas quoi en
faire mon gars mais je vais faire choper
après vous allez brûler on va essayer
d'aller brûler ou tu sais quoi non gérés
en cours à poil on aille a plus de
problème ça oui oh oui c'est beau ouah
ça marche [ __ ] ce fantastique ou
maicon est ce que c'est un corps décédé
peut-être mais moi j'ai rien fait
regarder je t'ai aubin j'ai entendu des
cris je suis venu je vais gmt a pris le
temps de m'habiller vous doutez bien que
c'est pas moi je suis baissé parce qu'en
fait je peux pas aller en cours donc je
suis pas en tenue de civil elle madame
bien faire course te plaît j'aimerais
finir la journée à mon dieu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ici [ __ ] c'est affreux
mais madame faut prendre le corps pour
les placer au plus juste déplacé le
corps faut pas laisser ça dans l'école
ah c'est ça elle a perdu son soutien
gorge il faut que je retrouve et que je
lui donne il me semble soit cinq ans
j'étais dehors quelques pas à temps on
va le chercher
et après elle voudra bien de suivre aux
[ __ ] l'empreinte tarifs derrière la
dune h crois que c'est ça son
soutien-gorge l'a trouvée je rends bien
dans tout le monde gagnera totalement
humiliés bonjour c'est pour toi tête et
du cou est ce que je fais moi même
suivre ya une porte à coups des
démarches pour avoir dedans et à casimir
c'est un truc de ouf et moir et elle est
contente elle est tout tout heureuse
toute naïve l'a jamais rien n'hésite pas
la [ __ ] de tutelle en tout temps d'y
aller
ben là tu t'endors en position foetale
des cheveux dépassera peut [ __ ] vous
qu'on lui coupe les cheveux d'un second
sera pas gagné c'est bon allez on va en
cours
et là c'est là vous allez voir
l'incroyable les douches ou palais à la
cape
[ __ ] je suis content j'ai galéré mais
enfin on y arrive et regardez mon gars
elle est accrochée une [ __ ] de chaise
alors quoi faire c'est très simple on va
torturer on peut torturer bien gratuit
pour les gens alors on va la torture est
allé aux tortures c'est parti vous allez
on veut en venir c'est très très pervers
est ce que je peux aller la torture et
salut je vais te torturer en 18 heures
du coup je rate l'école par contre ça
c'est pas bien voilà on passe direct à à
tous d où on retourne dans le sous sol
où elle est attachée et là elle commence
à un peu devenir fois le regardait les à
45% et là on la ressort sur 18 heures 23
0% elle va pouvoir faire un truc
horrible vendredi bon dernier jour
d'école du coup par contre ça sympa en
mer dans l'art populaire torture elle
est déjà 0%
de quoi lui dire va à l'école vas-y à
moustoir c'est horrible regardez aux
délais qu'on ait vus tous les deux ans à
venir avis elle dit je suis inutile elle
est vraiment en mode pas bien la pls est
total pour cette femme est là ce qu'on
peut lui ce qu'on peut faire c'est
exceptionnel on peut prendre un katana
retient
ok [ __ ] qu'est ce qu'on va faire ta
voix je m'éloigne ans et j'avais un
[ __ ] j'ai réussi mon plan diabolique
mon gars je suis trop une terreur qu'il
kiffe qu'il est un mec au lp quelqu'un à
tout le monde qu'il est un dieu c'est
horrible
et là qu'est ce qu'elle va faire à cette
paille c'est pas moi [ __ ] c'est pas
d'ma grèce est ce qu'elle va tuer
[Musique]
oui voilà c'était la politique de beauté
alors c'est bon je peux passer devant tu
vas pas me casser les couilles à cette
fois j'ai rien fait bâtarde novascale
gcos n'est à l'arrêt laisser une
dictateur elle ferait attention à re
bonjour la caméra s'est arrêtée bonjour
je suis une mère large où il montrait un
truc qui est terrible attention très
terrible en fait il y a des gens qui
font du [ __ ] de caractère elle est par
exemple la bête et ça paye moi [ __ ]
l'avenue quoi regarder derrière ça ne
pas été vu au c'est dommage pour toi
alors oui ce que je fais aussi le
doublage de mickey tout ce qui est pas
viril ce mois qu'il double en fait
chaque nominé connu il ya des gens qui
ont offert les héros voyez plus par
exemple il ya peut-être faire le aux
plages les arrêtés juste avant oust et
chaud en fait c'est un mec fond du
karaté et arts est regardé elle vient
d'arrêter à la baule c est lui sorti
chez sa mère normand qui font du karaté
pourquoi personne au fait du karaté
regardez lui c'est perturbé du tout
madame je pas le temps de m'écouter
c'était les nouveautés de rigueur et
simulateurs on peut maintenant torturer
quelqu'un jusqu'à ce qu'ils but un autre
quelqu'un avant de buter lui même d'une
pierre deux coups ça s'appelle c'est
beau j'aimerais bien défoncé quelqu'un
au cutter
ll nuls elle n y regarder elle est nul à
chier est nul à chier a lâché je la
vends challenge devient animations du
monde
non non on en lui c'est un master up
mais c'est trop dur pour moi vraiment
bravo aux karatékas du bas vie vous
détestent et voilages ans doit prendre
ses vidéos sur des simulateurs n'était
pas allé mais ça vous a plu on se trouve
très vite dans une prochaine je pense
qu'avoir des très belles nouveautés qui
vont arriver en soi une petite vidéo là
tu dors un mois un mois et demi moi je
m'en vais me faire un steak pommes de
terre voilà c'est ma vie s'écoule bon
appétit à tous ces nouveaux ces nouveaux
donneurs style dans cette europe la
savoyarde ont sauté dans une prochaine
vidéo chat au monde portez vous bien
pire
[Musique]